avec l'automne sonneurs de renouveler
les garde-robes on est comme chaque
année les bourses aux vêtements
fleurissent sur le territoire une
pratique apparue au début des années 60
depuis ce matin sur la place de
l'ancienne comédie pour la première fois
à limoges un marché d'un genre tout
particulier c'est ouvert la bourse aux
vêtements organisée par l'association
familiale du limousin avec le
développement du prêt-à-porter tout
change
le vêtement se démocratise se diversifie
les français découvrent le plaisir de
changer de vêtements souvent et pour
vider les armoires encombré la solution
c'est la bourse où chacun trouve son
compte
ça permet aux gens de pouvoir innover
incuber sur toute vidéo
car avant cette date s'habiller c'était
ça la mode durer plus longtemps ma mère
et rob plusieurs années ont choisi c'est
quelque chose de belles qualités
alors c'est longtemps avec mon c'était
presque pour la vie certaines mamans
confectionner elle même est tenu de la
famille elle reprise est tricoté et le
tour était joué
grâce à la bourse aux vêtements fini les
corvées de reprise âge et voilà que les
mamans couturières craquer abondonne
sont leurs machines à coudre
j'ai habillé mais si ce jusqu à peu près
12 ans et maintenant j'en fais moins
parce que nous avons amorcé une bourse
aux vêtements
nous pouvons acheter vraiment des choses
en très bon état qui sont nettoyés et
qui sont récents pour vraiment très peu
chez imaginé pour les plus démunis
l' usage de la bourse aux vêtements
s'étend rapidement à l'ensemble des
familles prix modique et choix illimité
voilà la recette du succès alors qu'ils
apportent les vêtements et qui les
achètent
ceux qui en ont besoin
ceux qui veulent vider leurs placards
sont les dames qui ont envie de changer
de robe parce que la couleur noire est
pas parce qu elles ont grossi les
grilles parce que j'en sors grandi
finalement ça rend service à tout le
monde alors je crois qu'on peut demander
est la meilleure preuve c'est que les
habitués reviennent et nous amène notre
année crise et baisse du pouvoir d'achat
oblige les bourses aux vêtements ont
retrouvé leur caractère social mais elle
surfe désormais sur la tendance du
consommer durable
[Musique]